okay you're an outspoken advocate for
both hustle and self-awareness yeah so
if you had to put them in order even if
it's a 1 a and 1 self awareness self
awareness not when you know who Lou yes
when you know who you are
hustle sexier yeah like it would've been
cooler for like the people listening for
me to say hustle
cuz it's cooler self awareness is the
game so I love sports I don't play a lot
I'm old down 40 I try to play I wish we
could've play this morning I'm sorry I
had to miss it but what do you would
have noticed very quickly is I have no
left hand because I didn't have older
brothers I don't have anybody teaching
me to go to my like when my brother AJ
is a much better player because when he
was 9 I forced him to only play Lefty
which have allowed him to have both
sides of the ball I'm self aware that I
don't have a left hand one of the
reasons I don't get the ball stolen so
much and when you play pick-up
basketball is I try not to go to that
direction that much
if somebody's smart and paying attention
they'll recognize it by game two or
three and they'll be able to defend me
better but when you know yourself you
win in business the reason I've been so
successful is I know what I'm good at
and I know what I'm not good at and so
when you actually understand yourself
you many people are listening right now
that loveth let --ax and think they have
a jump shot and think they can take it
to the rack that's right and when and
instead of taking a step back and saying
I suck going to my left and then working
on it yeah they continue to [ __ ]
themselves and they never Excel self
awareness in sports is that and in
business it's people that think they're
a good marketer or it's somebody who
thinks that they're good at selling or
somebody who thinks they're good at HR
or being a leader and the truth is you
may not be and I think you know you look
at you know I'm friendly with draymond
Green his self awareness has made him a
much better basketball player because he
knew what he was good at yeah and Tom
Izzo did a great does a great job with
that if you look at why Michigan's you
know you know this better than I do I'm
just I'm just dangerous enough to add to
this conversation where he puts players
in a position to succeed then the whole
team is better you know and so my
friends if you're listening right now if
you just know who you are if you know
that you're short if you know that
you're fast if you know that you can
shoot if you know that you're a good guy
if you know that you're a patient gal if
if you know who you are and do more of
that and then also understand whether
you need to work on those weaknesses or
not so for example business I think
actually not working on your weakness is
a good strategy because you hire or
partner up around it
the problem with basketball is just
being cliche here is if you never work
on your left hand you're never gonna
have it so you know and it limits you so
I think self-awareness is the single
most important drug in society well why
do most people lack it is it ignorance
or fear boy I think in a lot most people
are not self aware I'll be fully
transparent I wasn't self aware - about
three years ago when I went through
counseling for a divorce and it
completely transformed my life you seem
like someone that's been self aware
forever so I guess the first part of the
question is how long have you been
self-aware and where did that come from
and then second is why isn't everybody
else you know it's funny I think and
this gets into a whole nother thing I
wonder if true self confidence like true
is actually the unlock I think I've been
self-aware a long time because I had
crazy self confidence when I should
enough when you're a freshman in high
school and you're 411 and your book bag
is bigger than you you shouldn't be as
confident as I was do you know what I
mean and that goes back to great
parenting and that does is I think the
reason I've over indexed in the business
world is I think people see my purity
which is I want to be the best yeah but
I don't want to at your expense
right I just want to be the best and if
I'm not Mazel Tov you're better
congratulations and if I am I'm gonna
stick it in your mouth and I'm gonna
talk [ __ ] and I'm gonna [ __ ] own it
I'm gonna love it
right but if you beat me like I this
last week we went to Chattanooga
Tennessee
we played the bellhops guys from a
start-up down there and the Vayner guys
we lost all five games and I'm pissed
and I hate them and I hope their company
goes out of business but I give them
respect and they wanna listen when you
have a six seven walk on to Auburn we're
playing pick-up basketball you lose but
I think the punchline is I respect the
game even at my own expense I don't
wanna be a hypocrite
I think there's DNA I think there's
parenting I think there's a lot of
variables if you didn't get lucky with
the right environment you didn't get
lucky with the right parents it's gonna
be harder for you I think I was blessed
I do think I was lucky I believe that it
doesn't take away the fact that it's
true you know like people say well
you're lucky fine but it's true people
say oh you're a white male in society
you have a better
you're right but it doesn't change
what's happening like I think too many
people get romantic about how the way
they want it
hobbies in Birmingham Alabama and
somebody said hey gentrification is
happening how do we let minorities win
in business I'm like when in business
and I used basketball I go how do we get
more white players in the NBA they have
to be good yeah like the market is the
market is the market is the market is
the market and so I would tell you going
on the life kick right now nobody cares
about your problems I just have bad news
for everybody nobody cares that you
don't have time to practice nobody cares
that you can grow up with money
nobody cares they came from bad
neighborhood as a matter fact you know
why thinks in the worst position in
start-up business world rich white kids
cuz they're [ __ ] soft yeah and
they've been pampered and private
schools and Ivy League school then they
come and start a business then the
market says I don't care who your mama
was I don't care what daddy comes with
it daddy can't donate to the market to
make you win got it and that's why my
kid for example Xander Vaynerchuk if
you're listening you're four years old
you will not score a basket at home the
reason you have zero baskets on me is
because the markets not going to treat
you any different than daddy's treating
you right now so if you're listening to
this right now on recall and you're 13
and you're plotting how you're gonna
beat me on 101 tell you right now if 9
you're I'm 49 I'm in the best shape of
my life on a beating a [ __ ] ass until
you can actually beat me yeah but when
he does it'll be real it'll be pure it's
why AJ's a better player than me AJ when
he beat me at 16 or 17 first of all it
tasted delicious
yes and second of all it's because he
key became a better player and now I
work my face off to try to beat him yeah
awesome hustle and hard work are these
synonyms or is there a difference I know
you tend to use the word hustle yeah
yeah I think that I think there's slang
of the same thing I mean look guys
nobody's been successful on pure talent
right like again I'm being very sporty
here because I love sports and I love
the basketball stuff like if that was
the case the number one pick in the NBA
Draft would always be a superstar like
it's not just talent it's why it's why
all these can that's why the NBA Draft
is such a crapshoot people look at
intangibles and talent too much yeah
that's why draymond can go in a second
round when it was black and white he was
the heart of that team and he's gonna be
a good player like it's just real yeah
like like there's a lot more drayman's
and waiting Corbet's than you realized
they just come in different shapes and
sizes they don't have to be Wayne
Chrebet since sanity football pretty
much the second-round pick so it's not
bad insane
it comes like you know pick 11 like why
stuff not number one overall you know
you went the Davidson you like you know
like there's a middle but intangibles
the speed or the set but you can't you
can't judge heart and the intangibles
are everything in life and hard work
there's way too many people that give up
under adversity especially when they've
had it easy if you're an NBA player or
if you're a whiz kid you know business
kid that went to good schools you've had
it so easy what happens when they punch
you you know that leap from college star
to NBA start hardcore that's a whole
different world
a lot of those kids fail because they
got punched in the mouth for the first
time they were the best player in middle
school they're your best player in high
school and they were even the best
player in college and then they get to
the pros and they lose then you know
back to business a lot of these kids
lose because they never were the best
player they were to fake best player to
best student yeah great you got an A in
business class that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
that's like me being good at NBA 2k
that's fake what happens when you
actually start a business so I make a
lot of parallels from business and and
sports and I do think Hustle is actually
one of the two core you know two core
ingredients it is it's hard work and
hustle slash talent that's the formula
always and forever because timing is
talent you can force yourself into any
timing I know that meditation is gonna
be big I know the eSports are gonna be
big that's not you know that's not
timing that's my talent of observing
consumer behavior and making bets I
didn't get lucky I didn't have a talent
for inventing my Twitter and Tumblr
stock right that wasn't luck that wasn't
timing that was the world is gonna be
all about social media I'm an invest in
Facebook Twitter Tumblr that was talent
that was understanding where humans were
gonna be so by your definition of talent
how much of it is something you're born
with and how much of it is you counting
born craft born and then the hard work
is banging away good like I had people
intuition but I maybe didn't deploy in a
business world and then I was just right
about trends and I could always you know
be on my bowling team be like I knew it
was gonna be big but didn't do anything
about it I didn't know how to deploy it
that was just intuition
that I was just a good guy at the bar
you know got it telling his wheel guys
oh for sure like you see and every day
go look at third graders playing bass
well I don't know how much how young you
go or what you see like it's there like
I was making money as a six-year-old
selling lemonade and then baseball cards
I didn't read a business book I was six
and there was no time to hone my talent
it was in me then I put in the work
every day you know I associated with
athletes because I punted school to like
yes so everybody knows everybody who's
made the league and whenever League they
stopped caring about algebra and science
somewhere around second grade I was the
same I got these in F's my whole life
because I knew I was gonna be a
businessman and long before businessmen
and entrepreneurs were gonna be cool I
fought the system I had this self-esteem
to pull it off I thought my teachers
were wrong I knew I wasn't a loser you
know I'm in the 80's 90's kid when
education was the whole game there was
no entrepreneurship and I fought the
market and did my thing and it worked
out for me what guide your
decision-making mostly now is it in
stinger experience legacy I make most of
my decisions now based on what is it
gonna mean to my legacy it's quite vain
actually it's me writing the history of
my life in real time but a lot of it
comes from legacy I want to know how
people think of it you know how nice it
is to hear your intro if you don't like
somebody tweeted that they think I'm a
good guy because of the things they've
heard from you see one of the great
things is the truth is undefeated doing
the right thing is always the right
thing like I have no idea who you
influenced or who you know but just
doing the right thing by anybody you
come across you just never know and so I
like a good I want a good legacy it's
like telling the truth if you always
tell the truth and you must have worried
about what when you've created last
question for you my friend I'm guessing
you started vaynermedia because you saw
a void in the digital media space it's
that why you started banner sports uh
it's not why I started vaynermedia oh
okay and it's not why I started Vayner
Sports Manor media I started I started
vaynermedia because I wanted to build
the greatest marketing machine of all
time then by businesses and run it
through it okay I didn't realize how
horrible the other agencies were at
digital and specifically social
marketing and that's why I got to build
a very big company
out of lack of competition okay no joke
even though it seems like a competitive
space as far as Manor sports god what a
potpourri of circumstances I
I basically was wearing a weird jet
jersey that somebody took a picture of
the agent of that player hit me up we
created a relationship he had a very
small agency called symmetry sports we
became friendly he had his own business
dynamics in parallel on top of that
narrative that I'm telling you my
brother AJ has Crohn's disease he wanted
to get out of vaynermedia because it was
a lot of pressure and he didn't like it
anymore
that other guy Mook cost me one day
randomly and says do you want to buy my
sports agency I'm thinking the back of
my head maybe this is something me and
AJ can do once he's that a veiner in a
year it doesn't seem like that much and
then I said yes as an entrepreneur and
then what's happened so I went with my
intuition and now I'm realizing oh my
god these kids are not being I mean whoa
I mean these agents are not you know and
I don't I don't want to be unfair and
paint everybody the same way but a
stunning percentage of these agents
really don't give a crap about these
kids they're it's a meat market they
could care less what if I did what I did
in the wine business and the advertising
and startup world what if I care more
than everybody I have a feeling that
caring more in this business actually is
going to give me even more legs you
don't know my dream is if and when and I
think it's when when we do the NBA I'm
gonna stay in that genre because we're
doing NFL first yeah then I get the
number four pick in the NBA Draft and he
has a Paul George like injury never
plays in pre-season never place fourth
pick in the draft and then I take care
of that kid for the rest of my life help
him learn business work with him get him
into a startup write a book about his
adversity build a podcast around him
like change his life have a show the
world what I'm really doing here which
is anybody that signs with Boehner
sports it's for life that was me
spinning into my hands it's it's
everything it's everything this kid
right here Vernon Adams are one of our
first clients when I bought into the
agency it still says cemetry treat team
as you see on the jersey up here yeah
can you get drafted he was supposed to
go into fifth or sixth round but he was
like
Santa fell deemed them to undersized he
crushed at Oregon for anybody's
listening then he doesn't even get UDF
aid which was stunning where's he now
the CFL and we spent a lot of money to
put them in the right position to
succeed on a five hundred dollar
commission check always do right always
do right cuz he's the best dude
his family's the best I still think he's
gonna do a Warren Moon and Doug Flutie
and coming in a felon dominate it's
gonna feel better than ever
and if it doesn't that's just the way
the market reacted and I just know that
we'll do anything we can to do right by
him so I think in the I hope when I when
I die that some of the conversations
around my death are well he changed the
sports industry forever because when he
started Vayner sports with the other
guys
what MOOC Brian AJ and Gary did at
Vayner sports was they took care of
players in such a way it forced rock
nation it forced CIA if force Drew
Rosenhaus it forced Ghana if forced all
these people to care more just to
compete with them and it changed the
market forever I love that legacy that's
a hell of a legacy thank you so much for
you thanks for having me appreciate you
brother
let me man